Last question today, we sort of alluded to
it in the first, uh, in the second question
is the battle between social democracy and
democratic socialism.
One worth having.
So the, there are two answers to this.
Ideologically, there is a major difference
between a social Democrat who believes in
a capitalist system that is well-regulated.
The coroners are sort of sanded off to make
the system work better for more people.
It sets a floor, it sets a ceiling.
We've talked about social democracy, that
versus socializing the means of production
as an actual socialist.
There is a world of difference between those
two ideas.
So the debate between social democracy and
democratic socialism is not just worth having.
It's an incredibly important debate that separates
drastically different world views.
That's the theoretical answer.
Now, in modern American politics, we are not
at risk or we don't have the possibility of
going to democratic socialism anytime soon.
I've said this before, when Donald Trump gets
up in front of a, you know, the state of the
union and during the state of the union address
and says, we will never be a socialist country.
First of all, he doesn't know that things
can happen over 50 years.
You know, over 30 years, over a hundred years,
that Donald Trump simply can't predict.
So it's a dumb thing to say, but there's also
no risk that we're about to become a socialist
country.
The serious reforms that are being discussed
right now around healthcare, around inequality,
around education, public transit, housing,
all of these things, the risk is that we go
slightly more in the direction of social democracy.
And so I believe that in in an academic sense,
in a theoretical sense, we should be discussing
social democracy versus democratic socialism
in the immediate, the goals for both are probably
the same.
If you are a social Democrat, you want to
get to universal healthcare coverage maybe
through something like Medicare for all or
other types of plans that I've mentioned.
If you are a democratic socialist, that still
is the next step for healthcare, which gets
you closer to what you ultimately want.
It's an academic debate right now.
It may become a practical debate at some point
in the future in the United States, but we're
not becoming a democratic socialist country
anytime soon.
There, uh, effectively, no, almost no democratic
socialists in positions of power.
Even some of them who call themselves democratic
socialists are advocating policies of social
democracy.
So have the debate, but the next steps are
very similar, whether you're a social Democrat
or a democratic socialist.
And I hope that we can unite among making
those accomplishments a reality.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Become a member or a patron
to get instant access.
Join at www.join.me.orpatrion.comslashandgaveitbackthedavidpakmanshowatdavidpakman.com
[inaudible].